so here's a cool psychological study so
it's called the marshmallow test and
maybe it's even a reliable study even
though it was done by social
psychologists it's probably replicable
and it's a nice study so you take small
children and you bring them into a room
and you put something that they would
like in front of them a marshmallow and
you then you torture them basically you
say see that marshmallow and the kid
thinks yeah I see that marshmallow
it's like you can have that marshmallow
right now or if you wait I think the
experiment is ten minutes then you can
have two marshmallows and so that puts
the child in quite a conundrum because
they're being asked to trade an actual
concrete tangible marshmallow for two
hypothetical future marshmallows and
it's not that easy to conjure up a
hypothetical future reality that has the
same tangible significance as something
real right in front of you and so it's
amazing thing that people can do that
and so then experimental leaves and some
children grab the marshmallow and just
you know chomp that thing down right now
other kids they videotaped kids while
they're waiting and they do all sorts of
things they whistle they look at the
ceiling they sit on their hands you know
they try to distract themselves course
they're eyeing that marshmallow like a
squirrel lying and not and and trying to
restrain themselves and you know what I
see in that is that the child's
prefrontal cortex the higher cortical
systems are warring with the underlying
motivational systems more primordial
motivational systems that govern such
things as Hunger the hunger system
hypothalamic system says there's
something sweet and fat right sitting
there right bloody now grab that thing
and stuff it down now and I'm sure many
of you have a constant battle with your
hypothalamus with regards to sweet and
fat things and often lose so you can
feel some sympathy for the child but and
the hypothalamus has these tremendously
powerful
rolls upward into the brain into the
parts that we would associate more with
voluntary control and the voluntary
control centers have these little weak
ribbons going down to control the
hypothalamus since it's pretty obvious
if you know something about neuroanatomy
what part is actually in charge when the
chips are down and it's not easy for
children to learn to regulate those
underlying primordial impulses the ones
that are wired in the ones that we share
with animals but they do it and and and
the cool thing is this is what Walter
Mischel found he's the guy who did the
study was that the long-term outcome for
the children who can delay gratification
in the marshmallow test is much more
positive than it is for the children
that are impulsive and eat the
marshmallow instantly its delay of
gratification now it's likely that
that's associated with trait
conscientiousness although that
specifically hasn't that specific
connection has not yet been established
but they seem conceptually very very
similar so so anyways this emerges and
children probably between the ages of 2
& 4 something like that they should have
it in place by four because it's very
difficult for them to really interact
well with other children without having
that delay of gratification in place
because if you can't delay gratification
other kids don't like you because you're
you want everything your way and you
want it now and your lot you're liable
to temper tantrums and that sort of
thing you haven't got the kind of
self-control necessary to make you fun
to play with so you can see that
emerging in children and it's pretty
it's pretty interesting and and not only
that if it emerges it predicts positive
long-term outcomes
just like trait conscientiousness does
by the way because trait
conscientiousness is the second best
predictor of long-term success over the
lifespan in Western cultures its second
after intelligence and so in our
societies the people who do best across
time are the people who have high IQs
and who work hard and I would say that's
a pretty decent what would you call it
it's a validation in some sense that our
cultures are working properly because
what you would want I would say if
system is working meritocratic Lee like
it should and if you're trying to
extract resources from those who can
contribute at a higher rate than what
you would want to have happen is that
the hard-working smart people do better
hopefully if that's the case then
everyone does better hopefully